Aaron keeners did felau has turned it
back on the division and gone Rogue
teaming up with Baden Schaefer in the
Black Tusk following the events of
Warlords of New York we are introduced
to a new content format called seasons
in this video I'll attempt to wrap up
what has played out across seasons one
to ten because I've been told that some
people don't actually want to watch four
hours with my videos to catch up of
which you know that's fair I can't think
of the last time I watched a four hour
video so think of this as a quick
Roundup of the Season story so far
and can the division survive what comes
next
the volcano's death he had organized an
attack on Washington DC rogue agent
Jupiter was given the task of carrying
this out
Jupiter assembled her team of Rogue
agents and equipped them with the new
rogue Network smart watches that agent
Theo Parnell had developed alongside
Kina
while on Mission Jupiter would receive a
package keynote Center a sample of his
new weaponized Eclipse virus
but with Kina now out of the picture she
had it disposed of to her this operation
was about getting rid of the virus not
spreading something far more dangerous
Jupiter and Rogues have teamed up with
the cleaners for this Mission she
informs them of multiple reports of
experiments being carried out to
weaponize the virus in DC it makes it
very clear that the goal is to eradicate
the green poison and anyone who could be
spreading it
following the path of Destruction
division agents would eventually catch
up with Jupiter's Rogues and take them
out one by one
it was discovered that Jupiter was on
Roosevelt Island uncovering a newly
developed EMP technology from a cargo
plane that had crashed there some time
ago
this tick was capable of neutralizing
all non-rogue Network shd Tech including
the agent's armor
her plan was to recover all the tick and
dispatch it out to Rogue agents
Nationwide rendering the division
completely helpless
by the time division agents caught up
with the the cleaners had set up a solid
foothold on the island and were
preparing to use it as a staging point
for the mission of cleansing Washington
DC of the virus by burning it to the
ground
but the agents were too much for them
the cleaners were pushed back
even after Jupiter had them utilize the
new EMP gems against them they fought
through killing the cleaners the emps
and eventually Jupiter
rogue agent Hornet had history with Kina
they served together in the U.S army
long before they were recruited by the
division
Hornet saw them as brothers and would do
anything that was asked of them
during kina's attack on lower main
hidden he gave Hornet some of the
eclipse virus along with instructions of
how to create more
on top of this he tasked Hornet with
going to Washington DC along with four
other Rogue agents to recruit members to
his cause
the outcasts were the most likely
solution as they were currently without
a leader and in need of a purpose
but Hornet's Rogue agents weren't
exactly the most subtle in the movements
division agents had no problem tracking
them down and eliminating them
eventually exposing his location at
Tidal Basin
on it to the space to organize his new
Outcast recruits and get a supplies of
eclipse virus moved out of the city
but the agents were pushing through the
compound too quickly
on it attempted to slow them down by
releasing some of the virus around the
base
however it was too late the agents were
able to clear the outcast forces and
then haunt it in a stockpile of eclipse
virus
black tusk's specialist leader Barton
Shafer has been tasked with working
alongside the recently turned Rogue
bailau
she has provided him with full Rogue
agents but he is having his doubts and
shares his concerns with Black Tusk
leader Natalia Sokolova
but Natalia shakes it off saying that
this is an opportunity for Fey and her
Rogues to prove their worth as well as
keeping a business partners happy
Georges Schaefer to handle the
responsibility as it was him who brought
Fey to the black task in the first place
during the operation Sheffer continued
to receive unreasonable requests from
these Rogue agents until he eventually
decided it was time to contact feilau
they would end up organizing a meeting
on Coney Island to discuss the operation
and growing expenses
in the meantime jeffer's Rogues are
being hunted down by the division with
the assistance of someone or something
that refuses to stop and talk and
instead opts to disappear after each
encounter
from the outside the Schaefer and Fey
meeting appeared as a setup to kill Faye
but regardless of what it was intended
to be used for the shd agents would soon
crash the party before anything was able
to go down they would invade Coney
Island rapidly working their way through
the Rikers stationed there and meet face
to face with the entity that was
responsible for helping with hunting
down the Rogue agents
this asset or operative would be taken
down by the agents but he seemed to be
known by Shafer in Natalya in fact he
seemed to be working with them
the agents would turn their attention to
Schaefer after engaging with some of the
most elite btsu in their ranks agents
were able to catch up with them and
after a short firefight Schaefer would
become severely wounded
Kelso would send in a team to retrieve
an apprehend him
agents finally discover Intel on
feylau's whereabouts given her
prominence within the agency her actions
in turning her back on the division
making more than just another rogue
agent Target
for the agents this is personal
after taking down a team of Rogues they
would find out that she is Camp White
Oak with President Ellis
but by the time the agents get there
they has assassinated Ellis and is
attempting to escape the compound via
helicopter
blaming the division for Alice's death
she is surrounded by a large contingent
of black task forces
before she is able to leave the agents
catch up with her and disable the
transport
they is now forced to engage in a fight
against the agents she once worked so
closely with
they would eventually be killed by the
agents but after a death they would
discover that not everything was what it
seemed
audio logs left by Faye would explain
that everything she has been doing is
for the greater good of the division in
the country
her plan was to gain trust within the
Black Tusk and work her way up through
their ranks to put herself into a
position where she could take them apart
from the inside and her first Target was
President Ellis
she needed everything to look authentic
it needed to appear as if she was just
another agent defecting from the
division
so for this reason she couldn't let
anyone know what she was doing
on top of this she was working closely
with bud and Shafer who had lost faith
in the direction the Black Tusk was
headed as Natalia's number one man in
the btsu he holds a large amount of
intel on what Natalya and her partners
are planning
but for now he is still in a coma from
his engagement with the division at the
end of season three
seasons 5 6 7 and 8 are just repeats of
seasons one to four but not in the same
order which is a little bit weird the
only reason I'm including this section
in the video is to explain why the
content I'm about to run through jumps
from season 4 to season 9.
when the jtf was assembled in Washington
DC Captain Lewis would be placed under
the command of Colonel Antoine Ridgeway
when Ridgeway stopped taking orders from
above and started taking matters into
his own hands Lewis was one of the
soldiers who would stay loyal to his
cause rebranding themselves as the true
Sons
after ridgway's death at the hands of
the division General Anderson would take
the reins
Anderson would eventually have Lewis
carry out an operation in DC they were
hunting for something and have now found
it
loosen as men head to the Jefferson
Trade Center immediately and this is
where the division would catch up with
them
except he is all alone the last member
of his team
Lewis would explain that there is
something much louder at play here in
regardless of their differences they
should team up to bring it down
although they don't necessarily trust
him the agents agree
the division along with Lewis get to
work taking down the Black Tusk who have
taken hold of the site
while India Lewis wants the agents that
the btsu are not the biggest threat
present on site there is something far
more dangerous something he calls the
recruiter
agents eventually take down the Black
Tusk forces the recruiter having done
nothing but observe from a distance
throughout the fight would vanish
shortly after
however to add to this confusion the
agents would also find out that the
Black Tusk soldier who is commanding
this operation had an agent watch on him
with Isaac detecting an agent status
the agents pushed Lewis for answers but
he would simply tell them to get in
contact with him when they had finally
caught up with what was happening around
them
this operation also reveals and confirms
the cooperation between Natalia Sokolova
and Kelvin McManus
McManus turns out to be the Secretary of
Homeland Security and that he is his own
personal unit of covert special
operatives known to us as the hunters
being Homeland Security McManus is not
only aware of the shd from its very
early days but is somewhat responsible
for them
following the mission at Jefferson Trade
Center General Anderson has come to the
conclusion that the true sons are no
match for the division or the Black Tusk
so it's reached out to Natalia Sokolova
in an attempt to team up
Natalia sends out a team of Black Tusk
operatives to assess and work out the
viability of this new potential Alliance
however in the background many and Lewis
have been communicating
prior to more recent events many and
Lewis worked alongside each other in the
jtf all the way up until the day that
Colonel Antoine Ridgeway turned his back
on the government
the jtf around Ridgeway were faced with
a choice to fall back to other jtf units
or to join his new band calling
themselves the true sons in turn
becoming an enemy of the country
many fell back keeping to his oath while
Lewis sided with Ridgeway agreeing that
things needed to be done differently if
the country was going to survive
however now after ridgeway's death
although Lewis still feels as though
what he did was justified under Anderson
things have now changed and he wants to
help put a stop to Anderson and
Natalia's plans
he has managed to find at least 100 True
Sons so far who are willing to follow
him and team up with the division to
take Anderson down
but unfortunately for him Anderson and
Natalia are on to him and have been
watching for a while waiting and
preparing to see how this plays out
season 10 is still active at the time of
writing the script so we're still
waiting to see what ultimately happens
with the soon to be confirmed Alliance
but it's looking like the division for
the first time will have some outside
support for the battles to come
like I said at the beginning of this
video the intention was to provide a
concise summary of The Story of All
Seasons up until now yes I've done this
before but over many hours of rambling
and extremely average gameplay so this
was more about wrapping it up I had
actually hoped that I could make this a
little bit shorter but when attempting
to do so I felt as though too much of
the important information was being lost
but hopefully this answered the question
of What story did I miss in the seasons
that I see quite often being asked I'd
hope that I'll be able to finish out
season 10 within the script too but
there were unforeseen delays for the
content being released so perhaps I'll
update this video later
anyway thank you very much for watching
and extremist malice extremely remedia
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]